if you had to face flesh eating french
vampires what would you do you'll need
to confront your mother's bloodthirsty
killer terrifying creatures of the night
and hordes of Undead in order to stop an
Egyptian vampire God I'm going to break
down the mistakes made what you should
do and how to beat the vampire messiah
in Castlevania nocturn get a whole
bottle of Premium fragrance every month
for 97% less money than what you'd pay
for in the store now hear me out sbird
is a fragrance subscription that lets
you choose a new fragrance each month
and it is designed to last you the whole
month for only the price of one large
premium topping pizza and I love pizza
affordable subscription plans means that
you get 600 choices of the best of the
best to choose from I'm talking Gucci
Prada Versi to the most Indie of Indie
Brands like Skyler heretic and
confession of rebel and more these will
let you smell as good as those anime
voice I know hard to believe right now
I'm rolling with Cross River gorilla by
Sanctuary because I like to feel this
fruity as a jungle after a rainstorm and
I also like to have a dash of calculated
complexity with this one because it's
going to make you feel a beat in hot
weather and smelling of mixed green
notes and also on occasion I like to use
handsome devil by groom and Lounge for
when it's time to look dangerous and
sophisticated the spice and citrus leads
you to Redwood and coffee scents that
will have you smelling warm and cheeky
for when you want to have a night full
of fun a 30-day Supply will allow you to
try a fragrance out fully before
committing to a full-size bottle which
can cost anywhere between $150 to $300
oh my gosh or you can just rotate
fragrance with sbird forever we won't
tell thanks again to sbird for
sponsoring this video use my coupon code
htb 55 for 55% off at s bir that's less
than $8 for your first month available
in the US and Canada check out the links
below and thank you sbird for sponsoring
this video now back to the show this kid
will be forced to fight a vampire that
no one has ever seen before RoR Belmont
here is the world's greatest vampire
hunter part of generations of famous
vampire Hunters he helps his friend who
is also a sorcerer Maria hold a secret
meeting in the woods the country is
tired of Rich French people running
things and have decided to do something
about it they talk about French
Revolution things just as piercing
screams and hordes of bloodthirsty
Killers blast through for a surprise
attack RoR acts on his training and
takes out his famous Morning Star Whip
and easily Cuts this Monster's head off
Maria tells everyone to stay close and
summons magical animals to attack while
rtor takes out two incoming stragglers
she directs her powers to take out
another baddy while rer deals the final
blow with some throwing knives a
surviving vampire tells him killing the
them is pointless before the next Moon
Rises something known as the vampire
Messiah the Devourer of light will soon
rise and block out the sun making no
sense rer tells him to shut up and takes
him out without a care in the world
heading back into town they try to
figure out what the vampire meant Maria
says that this news could explain why
vampire attacks in this town have
increased because too many have started
coming to this small village and it
makes no sense looking over she thinks
they are all gathering at the only
private mansion in the area oh by a
noble and since vampires are snobs deep
down RoR wonders if they should inform
the church that hired them as bodyguards
about this and Maria hesitates saying
the church doesn't care about anything
but themselves but RoR convinces them to
ask them for a temporary Alliance while
they get to the bottom of this vampire
mystery reaching the church they meet a
man named mizrach and he lets them talk
to his boss and the man that annoys
Maria the most the head priest rtor
tells him that there's never been this
many vampire attacks before and one of
them just said something about a Next
Generation vampire arriving soon the
vampire Messiah Maria thinks they're
meeting at this famous Noble's Mansion
nearby the Marquee the head priest tells
them that the Noble in this town has
done so much for this area and they
should be respected but Maria thinks the
rich are all evil deep down anyways head
priest guy rolls his eyes but agrees to
help them out and lets RoR and Maria
take a closer look at the Noble's house
while he tells them that he'll send his
town spies around the area to find out
more information about about all of this
these two then head back home for dinner
with Maria's mother and basically the
woman who looked after RoR since he was
young named Tara meanwhile at the rich
Noble's House nearby this Noble vampire
complains to the other vampire friends
of his that hiding out in this town is
boring and he misses living in the city
of Versailles before the Revolution
began and that's when they receive
another dead poor person for them to
feed on and they plan to use all of the
corpses they have left over back at
Maria's house the main gang prepares for
dinner just as they hear a loud horrify
Roar outside rushing out they stumble
upon a group of monsters waiting for
them ones they've never seen before get
ready for a showdown with an unknown
enemy okay while this may seem like a
surprised situation RoR and crew did
everything wrong let me explain it's
1792 and France which means some serious
[__] is going on which could increase
the probability that more and more
vampires are escaping to the countryside
right now the country is turning its
love for royalty and order that they've
had for centuries up on its head and
this means that the country is now
starting stting to hate on anyone with
too much power including Kings Nobles
and even priests and while there is a
lot of reasons why vampires have always
associated with Nobles vampires in
general are representation of
unrepressed desires and hedonistic
Lifestyles their love for power and
control over their food would likely
mean that they would Target the humans
who could provide them with direct
access to power over their food source
unlike today where the diversification
of powers encouraged back then under the
fudal system developed in Europe the
kings and queens would hand off parts of
land to Nobles to own and look after
basically to keep watch over what they
couldn't and poor people could rent from
the land and pay the noble a fee
basically and because of a vampire's
need for a steady source of food
targeting the nobility in general makes
sense since they can get away with
killing humans to secretly feed the
vampires this plus the revolution
happening in the main cities in France
means that was obvious from the start
that vampires would also be hiding out
where the Nobles would be like in that
Noble's mansion that they just saw RoR
here should have been way more alert
from the start considering the location
they in this is a small commune located
Southwest of Paris with around 5.3 th000
inhabitants probably way less though
back then aside from a few nice churches
there's nothing important or notable
around here there's no reason for
vampires to be here other than the fact
that it housed a small amount of Nobles
in the area likely hiding out from the
violence in the bigger cities
interesting isn't it in general the risk
of living in the main city areas while
always more dangerous in terms of
intentional crime living in the
countryside in reality has always been
more dangerous that while deaths in the
Country Side were lower than City living
they on average have lower access to
trauma care and Physicians trained in
emergency room medicine any serious
injuries taken in the countryside are
far more likely to be lethal and this
goes for where RoR and his team are
right now living out away from the city
only makes sense on the surface but it
makes them extremely vulnerable to
surprise attacks if they get injured
they have no help coming their way
they're surrounded by dark forests on
all sides living closer to the city town
would have at least given them more
opportunities to use the innocent public
as Shields of meat they should have
expected this and now they're caught off
guard little time to react RoR takes out
his Whip and starts flailing while these
two girls combine their magic to power
blast these bastards miscalculating RoR
is about to get overwhelmed when they
get saved by two strangers as the help
sends the surviving monsters away and
Retreat RoR notices that this woman is a
sorcerer but a different kind The
Strangers tell them that they were just
attacked by things known as night
creatures human corpses brought back to
life but with Demon Souls inside she
says said nobody has made monsters like
these for centuries and only certain
humans known as Forge Masters can make
them this means that a human somewhere
nearby them made them she introduces
herself as a witch named Anette and her
human friend Edward they tell RoR they
have come from overseas and are looking
for someone named Belmont because they
have come to stop the vampire Messiah
RoR tells him that hey he's their guy
but finds out from them that this
monster they're up against will be
different than anything he's ever faced
before the next day the gang gets to
know each other and a net tells them
that she is the only Survivor left from
her witch family of boohoo and she was
forced into servitude for years if you
know what I mean at the end of her ropes
she one day accidentally turned down her
powers and that's how she helped her
people break free met Edward and a
magical sorcerer that was with him RoR
informs him that he lost his powers the
day he saw his mom get brutally murdered
and Annette finds it weird that her
sorcerer friend didn't tell her this and
tells them that they will need all the
help they can get because this new enemy
thereof against was born a monster
before she was a vampire and will even
kill innocent boys and girls if that's
what it takes to win revealing their
enemy's name as isabet ba tera's eyes
then go wide as she hears this name and
runs off crying RoR goes after her and
finds out that she knows who the vampire
Messiah is before Maria was born she met
her and her attacked dog drta in Russia
before she fled and turned her sister
into a vampire terara warns them that
she hangs her victims and drains them
slowly of their blood just enough to
keep them alive for as long as possible
while they get tortured to death but
Annette and RoR says no worries like
some naive kids and think they should
investigate the Noble's Mansion right
now terara begs them to stay because the
Sun is going down but Anette says they
are running out of time to save the
world and they know the risks RoR
assures terara that they'll stay out of
sight and just watch from a safe
distance and these fools just made their
biggest mistake they head over there and
they half ass talk about their power
stats and how they can combine their
powers in case [__] hits the fan Anette
says her family comes from African gods
and she has power over metal and rock
RoR tries to cope and shows off his whip
just as they reach the stream of running
water a vampire's weakness a net creates
a Rock Bridge for them to cross and they
sneak into the area to keep watch she
informs them if they follow the night
creatures they'll find the forg Masters
making the maybe but that's when Anette
sees the person who trapped her family
as servants years ago here in the
Mansion this guy unable to hold back her
emotions she accidentally starts
activating her powers right as the
vampires right on Q spot them and begin
charging at them okay well it seems like
everything went wrong with this plan
because it did everything could have
been prevented our current lineup sucks
they once again acted like dumb children
when in reality the only one who had the
excuse to act like this was Maria
because she's basically barely 10 if I
was RoR I would have first thought
carefully about who I decided to bring
on my team for example Annette while not
in charge was clearly the one leading
this Mission and that should have been
addressed from beforehand while she may
be extremely powerful at the end of the
day she's R's age and without R's
training experience while she has a
fighting Spirit RoR has no doubt spent
his entire life training for one thing
meaning he no doubt would have been a
better tactician from the start Honestly
though Tera should have been one leading
this so she also screwed the pooch too
but I could have predicted that Annette
messed up this Mission and got them
spotted right from the get-go her
backstory while tragic means it was
obvious that she holds a grudge against
the man that kept her in Chains the
problem with grudges though is that the
act itself has been linked to
reinforcing a sense of identity within
the person holding in all that anger and
the association of such identity means
that the person holding on to The Grudge
means it becomes a part of them and this
means that Annette made this man a part
of her identity and a key part of who
she is her desire to kill him is now
rooted so deep within her subconscious
this is the reason Anette struggled to
keep her cool when she saw her Target
and being so powerful it'd be like as if
gamra got suddenly too emotional
something so powerful should really have
been better taken care of and if anetta
didn't realize she was an emotional
ticking time bum then well then either
RoR or terara should have spotted the
science and pulled her off the mission
way in advance r tells everyone to
prepare for battle charging in they
clash with whips magical birds and witch
magic and they quickly realize they're
getting overwhelmed RoR orders everyone
to retreat knocking back dozens of
monsters giving his team a head start
reaching the river Anette tries to make
a bridge but sees Edward get caught and
die right in front of her eyes RoR
forces her to concentrate on her magic
allowing them to cross her half-made
bridge and Escape until the adrenaline
wears off and the emotions hit hard
meanwhile though Edward's cold corpse
gets collected by by some demons and
gets taken to a familiar place the
church that the head priest runs
dragging the bodies down into the
basement they Place Edward into this
machine and use monster magic and
Cutting Edge Tech to transform him into
the very thing RoR team fears most a KN
creature the next day Annette Mourns the
loss over Edward oh so sad but terara
says that it was not her fault and that
Edward knew the risks she tells them
that the man she saw last night killed
her mother back when they were servants
she tried to kill him before but he
escaped where RoR mother's killer known
as orlocks reaches their town and
inspects the church but gets caught by
one of the church's Knights misak
curious he tells mizra that he knows
that this church is making night
creatures for the vampires and wants to
know why mizra tells him that the French
Revolution is making people pick sides
and the head priest thinks he can save
the good old souls of France from the
revolutionaries by teaming up with the
vampires orlocks calls him and says
being loyal to the vampire Messiah will
only get him and everyone here killed
when she gets what she wants later that
night Maria introduces a net to other
revolutionaries in the town but suddenly
they hear innocent screams of people
nearby and they discover that the night
creatures have come back RoR tells them
to split up as he takes on this one
monster allette saves innocent lives oh
goody slicing through baddies but then
sees a monster in the distance with the
exact same eyes as Edward paralyzed with
fear Anette quickly gets saved by this
monster brutally ripping it apart behind
her the other Knight creatures
immediately spot this and quickly carry
him away against his will and all of
them head back to the church Annette
desperately tells the group that that
was Edward and Maria confirms her
suspicions and says that the church is
working with vampires the next day RoR
discusses with the group about what they
just saw and what to do about the church
terara says that the forge Master making
those monsters must be in the church and
that the head priest must be the
vampire's prisoner cuz he's a good guy
but Maria calls BS on that and Anette
tells them they must save Edward but RoR
says he's already dead cuz he's a
monster and she tells him to shut his
face and wants to rush in to save him
saying It's Made of Stone and she can
use that to crush all of them but Rector
stops her and warns her that they need a
plan first and they need to see if the
head priest is actually a bad guy or a
hostage terara then reveals that there
is a secret underground tunnel leading
into the church that almost no one knows
about and RoR wants to know why does she
know about it but she tells them that
this time she's coming with them
elsewhere orlock gets busy with mizerak
and finds out from him that the head
priest is also the forge Master for the
vampires he tells mizerak that he knows
know that his boss will try to betray
the vampire Messiah and use the night
creatures Army he's building for her
against her orlocks warns him that his
people are in a tough spot if they don't
continue doing what the Messiah want
they're dead and if they Tred to take
her down in the end they could win or
die and misra assures him that they're
doing it for their religion and for the
good people who still believe in
religion because this revolution has
caused people to be more divided than
ever and because of this he will fight
for God no matter what so he puts it
back in his pants and heads back to
church just in time for drta to arrive
the vampire messiah's Top Dog and she
enters inside MRA gets annoyed with her
pissing drta off but the head priest
tells everyone to chill out because they
have a common enemy and tells her that
thanks to the rich Noble his people have
provided enough corpses for them to make
18 KN creatures with more being made as
they speak suspicious of her mesak tells
her that the church is expecting her
Messiah to be the next Jon of Ark and
lead them out of this Unfaithful time in
the country drta assures him that her
boss won't disappoint she asks to see
some night creatures so misak gets
ordered to escort her down to the
basement not realizing that orlocks has
snuck into the basement himself in order
to do a little snooping just outside R's
group finally reaches the secret tunnel
and heads in reaching this entrance
terara opens the door and they hear the
night creature guards watching the
perimeter that's when Anette hears
Edwards singing and recognizes his voice
but they get spotted again gosh they
suck the group fortunately reacts
quickly and splits up to take on the
hordes and meanwhile warlock's nearby
spots the night creature machine in this
room and sees the magic instruction
manual telling him how creatures of the
night and this gives him some ideas back
in the main room RoR and Friends
combined forces right as they run into
drta and her crew with Maria spotting
the head priest confirming that yeah
he's a bad guy it makes terara realize
her man is evil as [__] okay okay this
seems like an impossible task but not
for me I would have been able to achieve
two out of the three of the gang's
objectives by just relying on sunlight
and lessons in Forge Mastery and scre
over Edward's useless face let's take a
look at their objectives find out who
the forge Master is and kill him save
Edward and see if the head priest is
working for the bad guys or not then
decide his fate are you freaking kidding
me their current plan is solely focused
on one objective based on how they
decided to infiltrate the church and
that's to do with Edward Annette once
again wanted to bum rush in and save
Edward with no plann classic move and
could only think of burying everybody in
the church with her powers if it all
went to [__] and Maria just thought to
go in and kill everybody including the
priest cuz he's a dick and all tear out
the only true adult with superpowers
here could suggest to do is to sneak
into the church through a tunnel and
vouch for the head priest if I was
terara and a better adult than her
before coming up with a proper plan to
meet our objectives I would first
address the elephant in this room or in
this case the night creature Edward oh
yes he's adorable he likely would have
been able to help us in terms of winning
this vampire War despite what Annette
says cuz if we think about it our
current team roster everyone here either
has powers training experience or a
little bit of both whereas Edward from
the get-go didn't have much of anything
except for a nice setup pipes really
sure he could swing a sword but in
reality he joined the revolution as a
man with passion and ideas not as a man
with anything useful at best he could
handle some humans but putting him
against vampires and night creatures
that is clearly a mistake which makes me
right and because of this it's pointless
to consider him in this plan at all now
with that out of the way I would then
pay more attention to the identity of
the forge master and who he could have
been before even heading in there by
just using some common sense it's noted
that Forge Masters can only be humans
and the art itself takes years to master
which means that someone within this
Tower would have discovered who the
forge master was especially if they were
located somewhere as highly accessible
and full of people as the church but did
you know there's another much more
subtle and faster way to become a forge
master and that is through making a deal
with a demonic being this would have
been much more likely the explanation of
what the head priest did and this
demonic deal to Grant someone forg
Master Powers also links to why Anette
thought Edward was still part human
originally Forge Masters take years to
master the art and put round Souls from
Hell into their night creatures whereas
through the Demonic deal this uses the
Original Soul of the corpse in order to
turn them into a night creature servant
and this could mean that Edward's
Original Soul would still been inside of
him and that's what a net saw which
means if I was them I would have instead
charged into the church during the last
hour of night when the vampires would
have been out and about and the church
would have been more empty allowing us
to sneak in and just deal with the night
creatures being Dawn also means that we
would have had found the head priest
sleeping and could have kidnapped him
and taken him hostage there you go you
see two out of the three objectives
you're welcome they waste no time and
the two groups charge in hand to hand
Anette fights drta but she pushes her
back allowing her to get a moment to get
to Edward while the rest cover her
reaching her old friendch she finds out
that he still has some memories of who
he is she apologizes for letting him
turn into a monster and prepares to end
his suffering but Edward then starts
backing away in fear not wanting to die
understandable shocking Anette that he
is still part human nearby RoR slays
demons with teror but Maria gets badly
cut and drta tries to kill her but the
head priest quickly stops her saying
killing children wasn't the deal
spotting a net she charges at her barely
giving Anette a chance to defend for her
life while Tara rushes to Maria's safety
the head priest tries to explain to them
that the world is evil and he's trying
to save it RoR acts like a tough guy and
prepares to continue fighting but that's
when orlocks arrives behind him and
reaches out his hand R's mind breaks
seeing his mother's killer and he loses
his [__] and tells everyone they need to
leave leaving everyone behind as he
bails forcing the rest to escape without
saving the world and without saving
Edward orlock then greets drta saying
he's been waiting in town to meet the
vampire Messiah because she is expecting
her and she tells the head priest to go
make more night creatures later that
night Anette finishes resting up and
tells these two he that she wants to go
back to save Edward but Tera says they
should wait for RoR to come back and
need time to figure out their enemy they
convince Anette to do some recut cuz
yeah that went so well last time
listening she then spots drta passing
through town following catches her
bumping into orlocks feeding in the
streets and she warns him to not feed on
the wealthy in this town since they are
trying to secure peace for now they go
for a walk while orlock asks her about
the whole world domination plan she
tells him that Darkness will soon cover
the sun soon and then all the vampires
can stop relying on the rich Elite to
strike deals telling him that everyone
across Europe is pledging their
allegiance to the Messiah he finds it
hard to believe why in Vampire could be
so powerful but she lets him in on a
little secret the Messiah is not just a
vampire but a goddess that drank the
blood of seet the Egyptian goddess of
war and Vengeance daughter of raw it was
prophesied that the time for her Reign
was when there would be signs of
disorder servants Uprising and War and
this is why the vampire rice has decided
to strike now and restore the natural
order of the world full of Kings
servants and peasants she tells him to
not worry his pretty face and that he'll
meet their ruler very soon while nearby
Annet hears all of this as the sun rises
the head priest pays a visit to Tara's
house begging them to he checks in with
Maria about her arm and reveals to them
why he's working with the Killers saying
that now with the Revolution going on he
doesn't know what to believe it anymore
the revolutionaries are looking at
religion as evil and lots of his priest
friends have now died he now wants to
make an army of night creatures not just
for the vampires but to stop the
non-believers from wreaking havoc and to
keep them safe and will tolerate the
vampires for now terara tells him that
he's not the man she wants knew and
wishes she never met him but he
accidentally reveals that he is Maria's
dad and tera's exad daddy nearby in the
town bar after good cry about his
mother's killer blah blah blah not
important RoR enters this bar to chill
out but doesn't have any money and then
this creepy old man then offers to pay
for his meal and RoR thanks him and
that's when this flesh eating Vampire
comes in and tells the same old man that
he is dead RoR reacts fast but discovers
the old man has taken his Whip and then
activates all of his badass removes
cutting off body parts and heads in
seconds he tells rtor that the whip is
heavier than he remembers it and walks
out of the bar leaving RoR shocked
confused and demanding answers of what
he just did RoR follows him and asks who
he is this old man says that he knew R's
mother because he is R's grandfather
Shust Belmont he reveals to them that
he's been here in France since RoR
arrived years ago and has been watching
him this whole time suck he told Tara
not to tell him but constantly give her
money to help fund RoR here he gets mad
at the old guy for hiding out all these
years and not living up to the Belmont
name but juice tells him that he used to
be the most powerful Belmont sorcerer
but after his wife and best friend died
he lost hope in life and lost his
magical ability and now just chills out
cuz life is pointless RoR tries to
convince him to get off his ass but he
tells him that evil will always win so
there's no point in fighting it RoR that
breaks down crying again with the two of
them unaware that monsters are nearby
elsewhere lost without Direction Anette
calls upon her ancestors and her trainer
the trainer tells her that while her
traumatic past fueled her energy until
now it is not the source of her power
and she must learn how to move on
mentally to find light in the darkness
and to not give up just yet in order to
be able to fight the incoming threat
meanwhile at the church the night
creatures begin hearing Edward sing more
and more frequently and his voice begins
to almost heal them this demon
approaches him and they chat Edward
finds out that this demon remembers his
name and convinces him that this isn't
their final fate upstairs Maria pays a
visit to her daddy just returning from
their house she tells him how
disappointed she is in him about
everything and he tells her that he must
do what he must do for God but says that
he will always protect her as long as
she doesn't stand in God's way just then
they hear crowds in the distance Roar in
excitement noting that the vampire
Messiah has finally arrived he tells
Maria to quickly leave not realizing
that drta has seen her back at R's
granddad's place they chat about life
when he goes to the bathroom taking too
long RoR senses something approached
them alarmed he takes out his whip right
as dota's men charge at him forcing him
to fight unprepared and underere
equipped he spots juice now in Chains
near him and soon gets disarmed and held
down forcing him to watch as this
vampire says he will end the Belmont
line right now but also will make all of
his friends suffer before they die as
punishment with no hope left and about
to die R's life flashes before his eyes
and seeing those he loves something
inside of him rups and he unleashes his
inner Fury and emits a beam of light
realizing that his powers have now
gotten reactivated this guy attacks him
but easily gets blasted with magic and
he Dodges and kills these two with speed
and precision the final boss tries to
escape but gets caught by juust who is
now broken free Rector then brutally
blows his face off and realizes that his
magic came back and now he has a job and
a family to protect okay while this is
all hunky dory what just happened proves
that R's brains is all about his looks
let me explain RoR here wouldn't have
had this problem and would have had his
powers way back earlier if he just
noticed the signs around him it's noted
that he lost his powers when his mother
died during a traumatic event such as
this a process happens in the brain
called neuroplasticity which occurs when
the brain basically rewires itself in
response to emotional trauma including
releasing hormones and chemicals similar
to a fight flight or freeze response
which causes cognitive processes such as
memory alteration and the defense
mechanism in order to Shield the person
from experiencing severe emotional
distress again and also if we look at
how rtor got his magic back it's in a
way similar to other physical activities
that require the use of our central
nervous system the more we do an
activity the better the brain remembers
that movement for next time and this is
what helps us improve producing magic in
this sense is similar as it requires the
use of physical movement concentration
and deliberate Focus all of which
require the use of the central nervous
system this is why it's possible that
when R's mothers died his brain due to
the traumatic event caused memory
alteration as defense mechanism shooting
him from the true pain of seeing his
dead mother but because magic was
associated with his mother and his
childhood the memory of the exercise of
how to perform the magic also got wiped
or buried deep within his psyche but
another way that he could have gotten
his powers back was when he met Annette
she told him her life story and her
powers she gained her powers only when
she was in a real life and death moment
and this triggered her Awakening this
likely happened as a direct survival
trigger response reor never once talked
to her about this since he lost his
powers when he went through some tough
[__] and Annette gained her powers when
she went through some tough [__] this
means that it's obvious by working on
his emotional state was the key to
getting his powers back honestly he's an
idiot meanwhile more vampire surprise
attack Tera Maria sees this and rushes
to try and save her seeing her mother
about to get killed it gets stopped by
RoR returning back and now a powerful
sorcerer shocking everyone here that he
is at his full strength and ready for
the greatest war of their lives heading
back to their house he apologizes to
Anette for running away but she tells
him she actually missed him since they
don't have many allies left RoR promises
to avenge Edward and getting a little
bit too cozy and makes him uncomfortable
back at the Noble's house orlock finally
meets the vampire Messiah she tells them
she's heard of the revolution in the new
world and plans to start an Empire over
there once she takes over Europe and he
will lead her to America making orlocks
realize that his new master might be
just a little bit too crazy the vampire
Nobles then head to meet with the head
priest and check up on their night
creatures and he tells them that before
they can continue their partner ship she
needs him to probe his loyalty to her I
must sacrifice something he loves to
show he submitting to her the head
priest tells her that nothing is more
important to him than God but she knows
he's lying and reveils that he must
sacrifice Maria mizra tells her that the
head priest has no daughter till he
looks at his shocked face the vampire
Messiah tells them that men are always
led by their own airies and they have
eyes everywhere in this town back at
Tera spot they work on figuring out how
the head priest is turning people into
night creatures and that's when orlocks
appears and says they're using using a
machine while he drops a book onto the
table the group gets their weapons ready
and head out to catch him while Tera
notices the book outside they split up
and RoR runs into him but this time he
isn't a scared little boy anymore and
he's ready to fight him orlocks though
keeps dodging his attacks and refuses to
fight him saying he must be the one to
destroy the machine producing the
producing the night creatures RoR gets
mad and tells him to do it instead but
orlock says that only human can destroy
the machine and only a human can create
night creatures and this is why the
vampires are using the church he tells
him to read the book he dropped and to
save the world before it's too late and
leaves heading back to their house Tera
says orlocks was telling the truth and
this book is a guide on how to use the
machine Tara tells them that she'll work
on decoding the ancient text to figure
out how to use it and destroy the night
creature machine while she does this
Maria sneaks off into the church to meet
with her father she tries to warn him
that they will soon attack this church
and destroy it in order to save the
world and he should get out of here in
case he gets hurt the head priest tells
her he can't leave because he needs to
help fix the world and sometimes the
only way to fight evil is with evil
itself he thanks Maria for caring for
him and they both smile and that's when
he tells her that her sacrifice for the
cause will send her soul to Heaven
striking Horror in her eyes as she gets
captured while misra sees this a little
later back at Tara's house she finally
decodes the book and tells the gang that
they can't destroy the machine because
it's made of pure magic they can however
send it back to where it came by opening
a portal Straight to Hell and sending it
back themselves and that's when mizrach
busts in the door and tells them that
the church will sacrifice Maria to the
vampire ire Messiah running towards the
church they notice the Sun get blacked
out by darkness in the sky blocking out
the sun and the vampire Army finally
escapes into the sky and the world
begins to turn evil while R's group sees
the horrors In the Flesh naive terara
thinks the Moon is just doing Moon
things right but the others think that
the God is seet has finally arrived this
group then runs into mra's men drawing
out their swords to stop them RoR
quickly draws up a new game plan terara
and Anette will stop the forge Master
machine while he goes to save Maria the
church Knights around them and mizrach
begs them to join their side but they
say no forcing him to unleash his inner
stud elsewhere the vampire Messiah
absorbs the power of the eclipse and
finally turns into sekmet the goddess of
war Mistress of drad Lady of Slaughter
she who muls she heads to the church to
complete the ritual with Maria's
sacrifice while orlocks here decides to
help Victor's group at the church the
head priest prepares Maria for sacrifice
just as RoR and Tera blastin incoming
night creatures try to stop stop them
from reaching Maria terara tries to put
some sense into the head priest saying
that the monster he's helping aren't
serving God meanwhile RoR ignites some
fire punches and starts blasting these
demons saving Tara and freeing Maria
Anette then heads off to locate the
forge Master machine while Tara begins
working on summoning a portal to hell
for her head priest tells RoR that he
should have taken the girls and ran off
because now it's too late RoR acts cocky
just as the doors open up behind them
trat enters with the Army ready to
brutally kill them everyone bumps heads
and gets dirty whipping up sick moves
magic and sexiness while terara
continues to work on the spell drto
almost kills Maria buta saves her with
his Morning Star borlock then appears
tell Briar's team as they continue to
push but that's when down in the
basement Anette takes on this night
creature but then realizes that that
these other two are trying to help her
approaching Edward she tries to break
him out but he tells her to leave
because his work here isn't done
revealing to her that his sweet pipes
have touched Souls down here she needs
to go and focus on stopping the vampire
Messiah back up stairs R's group puts up
a good fight just as seet enters with a
bang casually walking in all her minions
fall behind her and she easily gets rid
of RoR and head straight for Maria down
below Anette finally reaches the forge
Master machine and sees the portal into
hell that terara opened up for her using
her powers she tries to forcibly remove
the machine but quickly finds out that
she isn't strong enough just as hell's
portal quickly starts to vanish the
whole team quickly realizes that their
plans are failing all right well it
looks like this God is undefeatable this
vampire Messiah is just a vampire Empire
who drank the blood of the god segment
which is an actual God rooted in history
and religion but if this is the case it
makes no sense that RoR and gang didn't
do anything with this information they
found this information out days
beforehand if I was them I wouldn't have
let my big fat Belmont ego get in the
way of actually taking the time to dive
deeper into our enemy while specific
vampires such as her and drto would be
hard to find any relevant info related
to them specifically sekmet however was
a very famous God and one they could
have looked into sekmet was a warrior
Goddess that heard father raah sent to
Earth to destroy humans who threatened
his rule down here however after wiping
out the people against raw Sean didn't
stop her blood lust and kept on killing
and drinking the blood of humans and
almost destroyed Humanity in order to
stop her raw and the other gods came up
with a plan that involved emptying a
lake and filling it with beer dyed with
red ochre so it looked like blood seeing
the lake full of blood sekman drank it
all and soon became drunk allowing her
to return peacefully to ra himself by
knowing this I could have replicated the
same maneuver by using Tara and possibly
anet's magic to create a big leg full of
blood and lure the vampire Messiah to
nose dive head first like a moth to a
flame allowing her to become more Blitz
than Dom on a Saturday night with the
boys in Bangkok he really does get sosed
I'm not kidding the balls of their home
about to lose it all mizra charges at
sment but orlocks teleports him to
safety hearing Edwards singing from
below and tells drta to make him stop
out of moves Tera begs baby daddy to
turn his night creatures on her but seet
tells them that she doesn't want to kill
Maria but wants to do something better
than death and turn her into one of them
RoR finally wakes back up and tries to
attack but fails again and out of moves
Tara offers herself to sment instead of
Maria but sekman tells her that it must
be someone the priest loves the head
priest tells her he still loves her
making the New Deal hia tries to stop
her mother but Sean knocks her back into
ru's arms and him and the rest of the
group are forced to escape while the
head priest is forced to watch the woman
he loves turn into the thing he hates
outside of town orlocks drops mizra to
safety telling him that he can't stop
her and he doesn't want him to die
pissed off mizra tells orlock he
wouldn't understand cuz he lost his soul
centuries ago leaving orlock crying
while he heads back into town running
into RoR group he is updated that they
all failed and that's when they spot
drta and her minions nearing them and
they realize they'll never let them go
preparing for another battle drta
approaches and suddenly gets stabbed by
piercing white blade from the man
himself son of Dracula alukard drat dies
in a brutal death while alucart here
scares away other vampire minions he
reveals to ROR that he knows who he is
and tells them that they are on the
brink of feet but it's a good thing that
he's now here to help them out thank you
SB bird for sponsoring today's video now
be sure to click the link in the
description down below in order to use
my code for a discount